after all I'm with my good friends Chris
from chess cube known as chess explained
hi Chris yeah okay we had gained two
today and this time Anand was black and
girlfriend playing white he kicked off
with default okay so Anna doesn't play
the hyper modern night have sex but
rather commits more classically maybe I
pulled to the center with d5 yeah I just
got a pretty wide opening repertoire
again stone d phi is playing on yeah
various opening so he's playing what he
did play in the game is playing this
laughs he also placed some Queens gambit
declined variation but also java stuff
like the goon felt on or sort of
middle-of-the-road things like the noobs
oh is pretty much everything was
possible besides any semi semi correct
openings let's say he doesn't play the
king's indian or something he plays
classical stuff okay i'm so we're going
for Slav right so you have c4 c6 the
Slavs been very popular in the last five
years the most popular opening defense
against deform on say in the last five
years high level play yeah most likely
the wound felt is making a become better
combat combat come back yeah because
them as already a experience in Game one
when even a girlfriend plated term the
wound while also would have been a
possibility phone and to play but I'm
not sure maybe the sort of reversed
roles in the game in Game one sort of
cuz we need him to play something else
you never know but the goon friend would
have been possible as well okay
girlfriend went and I see three year
yeah and I think lots of players are not
really aware that it really
makes a difference what night you play
here 93 or not f3 is it's got some some
differences and one we will also see in
the game another place tonight at six
yeah and now girlfriend evening goes for
e3 yes just simply protecting
immediately that poem yeah having enzyme
bishop yeah the point of this move our
is with the knight on c3 ISM that this
way and I would let him move he doesn't
have yeah really attractive possibility
to develop his miss Bishop 1c8 oh yeah
in the position on with knight on f3 and
the light back on be one so if white
would have gone on move three Knight f3
and I could have played on this should
be fine maybe she should oh yes briefly
no not this a night f6 first I'm sorry
my sub 6 fast yeah and then he 3 this is
also a popular line also protecting the
porn but now black can play and you
should be fired without any problems the
difference is that this knight on f3
doesn't put any pressure on d5 all right
in the game position if black would have
played on move for bishop at five
instead of e60 I hear Bishop f5 then
white could play on seat XD five it's
usually played first seat XD five and
queen bee three yes this is embarrassing
sometimes in that using that kind of we
yes of the last move and Bishop do not
dancing yeah so now it's it's a bit bit
awkward you want to defend b7 but you
don't really have a good move to do that
so move like Quincy seven just turn
gives away t5 this is the problem yeah
in the in the other position with an ID
only three black and just play 27 and
it's fine it just would just literally
55 on and the move b6 you also don't
want to play because it really we can
sum the white squares you know
this is a Bishop Bishop b5 check also
just wins the porn movie yeah it's
officially a 5 is a pretty common yeah
let's say inaccurate move so of course I
didn't go for that but this sort of
limits blacks options here and yay play
t6 this is some the most popular move
isn't this a semi Slav when the bishops
hemmed in and yes sir as if not not a
real Slav or something so it's a setup
now it's always called Sammy's laugh
when you combine this ecigs and c6 move
but this sort of yeah the naming systems
of these openings is sometimes just
weird it's so okay it doesn't matter how
I discord it's a matter what what's
happening now Knight f3 yeah not much
else here and now this this is an
interesting point the my father main
move in this position is night BTW 7aa
and and this is also one aren't usually
placed for instance this has been now
reached and in the two deciding games of
the 2008 world championship match
against chronic ep1 those two black
games at the beginning at the match said
this was exactly with this opening with
night BTW seven ramnik played to Bishop
d3 and then we got those mainline
Marilyn variation yeah I'm absolutely
right kind of exciting and dynamic from
blank so yeah this is so this is can get
very sharp but he played a six which is
a sideline but an interesting one and i
played this myself in not shown two or
three tournament games and it's quite a
quite a tricky move from of course on
this level people are aware of those
little pitfalls here it actually sets a
small small trap so the natural move
Bishop d3 here which is the main line
against night bd7 is pretty
fishes here because now black can take
on c4 immediately and we can play them
b5 and c5 in one go so does my well
bishop guys maybe still yeah it doesn't
matter really MNC 5 and black has a
pretty comfortable version of a queen's
gambit accepted out of position if you
compare this with the night bd7 move out
on them like cannot play c5 because p5
is unprotected so yeah this is the
difference a sick sort of weights for
white to move the bishop and so this is
also the reason why girl from didn't go
down and this leaves blue-eyed with with
a pretty limited choice as Bishop d3
climbing yeah I think a lot of people
may be in our YouTube viewer audience
might think Bishop d3 is a reasonable
move but this tempo gaining gets a
positional kind of you know advantage
almost not what equalization for black
yeah it's a bit unambitious for widened
leg doesn't have huge problems so if
white wants to play for some some
advantage here they're on mostly two
moves be 385 well I don't think I
realized that myself I think I'd be
returned he playing picture to he free
ok but be free yeah it's like okay so
this is or c5 looks usually you wouldn't
want to play seat five but i suppose
black is not in a position to sort of
break out with be five anytime soon it
marks b6 sort of bind so is yeah that's
interesting yeah i think i was like
recently see fly still likes to place 45
in the long run but this is more
ambitious of course and but b3 is also
the bishop and the bishop strong i think
it's a main move out so um yeah no
Bishop before this is some wants to make
yourself yeah the week and a 5-1
diagonal yes maybe come back 45 later
some size but now that that might not be
the case is just it's annoying pin at
the moment and forcing maybe
an all good-looking Bishop move maybe
the bishop wanted to be on be too but
some this was the idea because white
cannot play there should be two it just
it's just not working because of 94 and
create five and you just loose material
so white must claim this Bishop b2 so
this is really a problem all right here
Brooks c1 I guess this is it is it
queenside say to hear because if rhombus
raysh you free and it's over that would
be pretty bad yeah so that's that's a
major problem these are the little
sausages which I don't think most people
would be aware of as a bishop d to
another app that move yeah this is long
also on the point why this should be
forced a good move because white must
play Bishop b2 and it really doesn't
want to arm yeah why doesn't want to
spin shut down because it just feels bad
there gives some holds on the queenside
and in general once you play beef before
I b3 you want to be sure don't be too
yeah so yeah but ok what why did with b3
was strengthening the center and sort of
make it more difficult from like to take
on c4 so as everything has got its pros
and cons here yeah yeah now that video 7
now it's very logical Malcolm and 53 I
think the next couple of moves are very
very logical so both sides now counsel
and now the bishop will there might be
some cheap hose if blacks not careful
with with 95 yeah so this Bishop
actually gets out of the way of any
cheaper now with Bishop d6 and it's
logically supporting d5 as well yeah
maybe you can show briefly if he would
have gotten a rookie aid for instance
the daughter looks pretty normal then
what can take on d5 here alright but
actually maybe I'm here Knight takes d5
protected out then C taystee 552 yeah
and then takes on c6 this is important
ah oh [ __ ] bad for the bad
banned for black yes Austin still upon
down and yeah black need to recapture on
c6 now and anyway we'll lose the pawn
you can also play Bishop a five but it's
a porn down for nothing yeah yeah so but
it's it's a funny trick you can easily
miss it so if you're not aware of it so
it's useful to remember so the bishop
has done its job anyway on before you
have to return yeah I know no it's
interesting um what goes look see one
here yeah I check this out on the chest
games I'm opening explorer during during
live commentary there yeah and the world
moves like evil that can be kind of shot
where whites or sucking porn of all it
um it's um yeah it's kind of tricky
there's other alternatives but it seems
statistically Roxy one was statistically
the most favorable yeah yeah a force own
and that one hundred percent sure it got
Auto Queen see to it sir has been played
yeah I think there's something weird
like a lot of beaten paths I think it's
to do with d takes and then e 5 and then
c5 and they denied a full believe it or
not with a white sacrificing a porn
temporarily and that would have made a
very exciting game but sadistically
blacks doing well in this variation it's
looking a bit list it's actually this
kind of setup here with the c5 the squad
sacrifice this has been introduced in a
game were actually girlfriend was
playing leg funny enough own in the 90s
the other game against Kasparov in his
well played this kind of worn sacrifice
I think he won in the end but leg was
okay um I'm not quite sure maybe Quincy
to rookie a door Queen see to Queenie
seven was inserted but okay this is
another possibility it looks e1 is may
be safe choice to to try to keep a small
edge here yeah so no rush fly evil evil
looks as though it's a firm attic kind
of
right but it's if blacks got a very hard
d fiber response but anyway 85 here is
interesting also rookie eights being
played a few times so if I've
immediately blacks willing to accept the
signaling dreaded isolated Queens pub
but he's liberating his pieces with e
five so on it doesn't even bother with
rookie aids it just plays be five
immediately yeah looks like the most
natural more than good position ok so
now whites is sort of justifying that
rock on see one now by taking on d5 so
the rook could be useful for an m4a
infiltration later yeah but actually
white doesn't play D takes e
interestingly doesn't go for the
isolated Queens pawn I mean in this
position he plays e for now um do you
think blacks just equal after or better
even after detainee yeah well like
shouldn't be better but it looks like a
very decent form of an isolated pawn
yeah because some yeah whites pieces are
just not well positions here yeah if you
would imagine this position let's say um
with the bishop and b2 and the bishop on
f3 instead of d3 are just now just see
the bishops on some different squares
line white would be I think slightly
better now that's pressure and um also
there would be the possibility to
exchange this be five bishop if it is
will be abie to White's one you could
play this stuff like alright a form and
exchange it and the bishop is on the way
it's simply in the way here yeah
pressure on d5 at the end of the day and
isolated pawn is also only we give ya if
it can be catch this voices yeah
exploits for weeks and also blacks got
that hook on e for the rook qualities
are going to be good around the isolate
point nothingness and as lot the bishops
are having a nice time here so yeah I
think this is it's not it's not easy for
white to create a blockade is it and
exchange off the dark square Bishop so
yeah I think decker black should be fine
it's nothing to be afraid of
and so I think you for some and mom
dishes try and trying to make use of he
has somewhat better development here why
does God you can play on c1 and it just
wants to open up the position as much as
possible so it's certainly am a decent
choice i think now she takes before if
like would have taken on d4 i think
white would go 95 but 95 i'm not quite
sure maybe metaphor looks looks a bit
weird but this this might be a might be
better right so try and get this Bishop
fine at that one and done yeah you will
get before you would get back to this
point anyway and he takes d4 94 think
was like let's see 500 that looks
hitting that bishop of course there is
the connection with d3 is inhibited by
that Bishop so that'll be here quite
look it looks nasty that yeah yeah it
should be it yeah better for blacker so
he needs to take on the five of the
night it's pretty much awesome but but
but I took only four yeah I think this
is one more natural also taking money
for and now we've got a 94 and the
exchange there yeah nf6 very very
natural I feel I think both players
identified this position as one of the
most critical now after Knight f6 I
think girlfriend might have spent about
half an hour in this position yeah I
think now I've got that he has a bit of
a crossroad see a few what what he
played was of course somewhat
simplifying but I also thought that why
should have a slight edge but and
defended very nicely in the game so
Bishop g5 person the main alternative
yeah so yeah I think that's the cross
Roger you're talking about details
versus Bishop g5 as the major crossroads
here
yeah this one here makes son makes also
a good impression pinning the light
threatening d takes d5 now yeah I'm not
quite sure what what black should play
here I watched the broadcast and also
the game but not this this part only
really watched a bit after that so I'm
not quite sure what was discussed in the
live broadcast what should them should
like play here interesting um I one that
is eat XD for possible if takes takes
takes you're gonna win the sorry no not
takes with right age to Apollo me you
take the Queen then you take on e4 is
that okay hmm yeah it seems to work so
here um white is not doing particularly
well this is Pawn down for not much yeah
I think I'm you good you don't need to
recapture immediately only four or you
could also think about capturing with
the night but this looks a bit unnatural
to me here but the night recapture yeah
because like h6 now on sort of air
forces why to take on at 6i guess and if
you need to do that you're pretty much
well for the first impression is next
just got the disrepair and turn but
you've got some pressure on b7 and black
sisters should be fine yeah tip the
ships are I important he also
threatening on h2 now almost like Queen
edge for Queen f4 all right yeah Jaime
yeah so yeah this a chance is very it's
very powerful isn't it so you're saying
that if Bishop age for that black might
actually play g5 here to win this year
just once piece
yeah I don't see any so diseny 20 back
at the moment he must have analyzed
listen a lot more in that half an hour
yeah yes I guess I guess what white
could consider after 9006 Bishop g5
takes two to just play some some other
movie it's not forced to recapture so
why can Bishop play something else maybe
you would have to prove compensation for
the poem hair yeah I most like that
could could be an idea yes he was
playing a lot safer is going
continuation I mean um interesting yeah
it's it's uh I think white white has sir
it's more than more than one option here
could also just consider a move like a
ch3 maybe instead of this should be one
just just just what I'm thinking of
offhand here to to sort of threaten to
take on d4 with the Queen you you so ha
good have the poor nein yes and I'm not
quite sure what's black what black
should move now just because yeah you
cannot move the c8 bishop I think p7
just hangs it's good point and under age
6 yeah but H sticks should be you should
be fine most likely you've got the same
issue no yeah age six just just just as
fine yeah yeah but maybe queen before
you can try to you can try to analyze
this kind of position there with the
pressure on the seven but it should be
should be okay yeah I guess he's so much
much further and maybe some other ideas
but Bishop g5 sm of course there the
more complicated term option yeah that
can understand I can really understand
the GTX d530 play because the
vision that we did we reach now which is
very much for us yeah Knight takes e4
scop move what he would do she play
takes on the 626 it's very very forcing
you should be three and yeah this kind
of position really really looks like you
can torture black phone for some time
and you have absolutely zero losing
possibilities so thus assaults always
desirable because the opposite color
bishes and the potential for as what was
played this night installment to d4 it
seems you know white could have kept
that night for a long time but it didn't
it wasn't the case um yeah my daughter
c7m the c7 square some entry point for
the Rockets always an issue and yes what
of this concrete position and I think
what what island played them made a very
strong impression first played Bishop f5
which is some yeah sort of logical
getting this this piece out but the main
point and the surprising point for me
also was this sequence now 26 96-94 and
now your ear is that reaction would be
like like in a blitz game yeah push g6
yeah wouldn't be to move the bishop yeah
because it seems to keep a bishop on a
diagonal which might be useful but if
you do that this knight on d4 how are
you going to get rid of it later because
that night it's kind of well holding
together black on the queenside isn't
that b7 form a little bit yeah you're
also sort of intuitively want to move to
bishop because he had a bishop is better
than a night so you moved away so it's
just that's just a normal thing to do at
the rook e8 was was a very a very good
very good choice and because was this
nice point you should bear for looks
like looks like a very strong move no oh
yes yes and black has a wonderful
YouTube viewers can if this was played
Bishop f4 why isn't this winning on the
spot so pop quiz here if we give you 10
seconds what
black play here 10 seconds starting from
now black could play Brooke efore that
only move so he had to make sure of that
that Bishop f4 wasn't destructive and
here black should be ok so so rook fe8
but the main strategic point is is
accepting this imbalance of Bishop
versus night now and is the bishop going
to be stronger than the night is the
main risk for black yeah the nice thing
is some you almost need to conserve a
little trick move like rafi aid and that
would have needed to see this fine at
once yeah so if you wouldn't have this
move and it would be really difficult to
to to defend this position so um it's a
very unspectacular game but I'm always
some quite impressed by those little
things like booty-eight because this is
the kind of position where you can
easily get into trouble against good
play by wide that if you do some
slightly slightly second-rate moves you
can easily get into into huge trouble I
would have hated this position at black
to to have against let's say good when
Muslim because you are certain to be
tortured forever yes Bishop g6 there's
permanent installments here the dark
squared Bishop which hasn't got counts
part is supporting that d4 night which
is going to be better than than these
two is that this default I so this this
is the torture position which will be
difficult you think for black to get out
of yeah it's just uncomfortable let's
say a walk c7 here it's white more
stories any APIs important yeah yeah
maybe maybe you can play rook c8 but
then you to consider I worked his heaven
you've got Rudy aid right maybe Roxy
seven was a bit premature not quite sure
maybe this versus was too quick it looks
27 a son maybe maybe swing just like
every to rule out efore and then maybe
even the king
come here um maybe yeah yeah it's
possible f3 need to consider Knight a5
of course but you don't want to exchange
the night really but still you bite with
them would then enter on c7 yeah this
this infiltration is scary even though
it's obviously can't bishops that might
make it worse in lot of cases sometimes
yeah White has got some some slide
things that that add up here the seventh
rank is got the King into play quicker
with King f2 King III didn't the low and
so it's it's still a bit unpleasant so
maybe it's um it's possible to toe hold
this but it's not the kind of position
you really want so I think was some
exact you see sort of neutralized
everything here yeah that's genius then
that work rookie I exactly silent genius
to play route FBI answers to avoid
torture yeah yeah and you enjoy what
what's also nicely done here so
definitely took on f5 deciding to to
want the bishop against night yeah
advantage slide um yeah static advantage
here mr. gypsy fire so yeah now this is
season I think Anna inside for moments
he was worried but then he realized
there was no way that white could use
the advantage of the bishop and I
couldn't say any way at all of what
using the advantage but here and now i
think it's um it's a matter of a couple
of exact moves and then it's really
nothing it's rife it's nice to to get
lurgy fall out of the out of the
position it wasn't an immediate threat
but so it's nice to anchor your unite
them ah there was one question i have
for you actually i will natalia ibogaine
england was a commentator on chess games
common mention in one of the side notes
a tree and i thought black could play h4
here isn't that possible i'm not sure
this would be such a fatal weakness here
this ice fall for the bishop I'm not
sure yeah really is this is difficult
it's not not something you can at least
I can tell off hand if this is a good
idea or not I would be cautious with
this yeah it is creating targets you
don't want to cry against for the bishop
later but yeah it looks hard to exploit
if you think what color should why to
attack this well maybe it's an idea I
wouldn't play h3 though it doesn't make
so much sense to me when just trying to
Vic this not if one wanted to evict the
night but why yeah doesn't really want
to do create witnesses himself so yeah I
think it's all on fairly own logic
anuraag ft one sort of threatening on
the seven but ok it's still the back and
we get back when so you'll see 8 so now
if the rook dead so enter of course
there's something like b6 now would be a
well I think this this would just it
looks to be losing tactically well
actually the back 40 rook see if I've
immediately back row mate follow me
route see ya they can get quick so yeah
yes version ok everyone is supporting a
one to make sure that she posed best
rookie to stuff like this and now f6
it's a very nice etching I've moved
taping some squares and yeah I was
surprised about the next black move but
ok bishop before actually what what can
I do much here so actually I Nigel sure
had a commentator next to him suggesting
I think brooke d 5 hair that that was an
interesting suggest that even though
it's going into this pin just try to
attack that as a knife as any if it's
worth us mentioning brooke d 5 what
black would would have done here maybe
just Jesus is g6 enough because then be
six is friend this is awkward isn't at
this
is g6 possible hmm I'm not yeah it's
some but it looks some it looks a bit
term near to me from what White's point
of view this move but ok it's a taking
the night but you're sort of in the sort
of half pin yeah yes sir 97 wouldn't
actually export because you don't want
to run into this to this do you yeah
real t7 I guess well brew tea sitting
here right so yeah maybe this same move
huh it's not threatening so much 57 but
it's still a tenancy phone hmm so yeah
but I may be black I know I can play
some other moves I think what about
actually route actually I did a quick
check on rookie fine would that be
terrible um I don't think it's good i'm
not sure how terrible it is but it's
maybe not losing but it tries hard to do
so it just it just gives you weakness
and five white captures yeah just
captures and if i'm not too creative I
just play Bishop e3 and get rid of the
rook yeah trying to try to make use of
my better minor piece here but I do have
a weakness on e5 weakness on g5 it's not
really necessary to get into this yeah I
think black and old but he just is quite
quick with this king so I'm snow no big
deal maybe maybe you can play will be
five we know that I think of it like is
very creepy near 76 maybe nothing yeah
then it's a good idea because it sort of
puts wide in this sea fowl pin you know
and yeah pookie fire yeah maybe you're
right maybe g6 isn't the end of the wolf
black hair yeah maybe now but what yeah
you're right rookie five ok five is good
I was really I was
my instant impression was wrong roboti
five rupee five is fine you can you can
just you can just exchange here and then
bring the king 2 235 and black is very
fine right yeah I just like being on d5
that is nothing yeah this the skins
gonna be [ __ ] get to the Samsung yeah
yeah in our King e5 and this is
absolutely nothing maybe maybe black
can't even try you just if Blackwood
would be would be a to mafia and you
play stuff like you for not h4 and
you're you're close to close to being in
real problems because you don't want to
play g3 alone i def 3 and so on you're
going example system no idea the king
position is just more important yeah
yeah yeahs then-rookie five looks looks
fine because you're just quicker yeah
all right okay okay so in the game the
way be looking if sorry yeah Bishop
before so you go ahead sorry yeah be
sure before yeah this is a I think wants
to get out of this pin on the C file and
now the slightly odd looking working age
seven was really really a bit strange
but it looks sort of unnatural to move
the King to the side but I think he just
wants to go to g6 and prevent an ayah
protect the night in case it gets
attacked right yeah so yeah once the
mines protective and reinforce then oh
yeah why it doesn't seem to have too
much here then the advantage of the
bishop yes as an answer doesn't look
like a it means much against the noise
yeah it's so it's a very nice night
position they're taking away some
important squares also or the bishop and
it cannot easily be expelled player on
f5 so
will see 5 was played with the draw
phone yeah you know it's um yeah of
course it's not the most inspiring game
but it can it can happen it's a many a
point of the qantas maybe move 15 wear
white had the opportunity to play the
should be five hmm can I not do it we
didn't see anything great now in our
brief analysis but maybe this is the way
forward she just quickly sorry okay in
this final position so what would happen
okay if takes what is black if would
black have taken here on c5 I assume
okay he doesn't need to we can also play
on kinky six maybe but I don't think
that taking would be so terrible yeah it
doesn't matter about what position of C
foul things yeah it just looks it looks
there's no targets there's no targets so
that's that's the thing okay so yeah
let's go back quickly review the game
into that critical position in
particular so Slav semi Slav with this I
six which is a little bit unusual you
mentioned Ferb and then considering his
Kramnik match if I'd like this and of
course that would have been prepared for
wooden at night busy so yeah yeah so
it's in some think it's a pretty good
idea to sort of stay in your usual kind
of position types but to vary a little
bit so this kind of line like a success
some quite useful I think so on the
young Zusi one and then law we've got
the simplification in the center so see
the e4 and now here after night to have
sex the critical position where we
explored a little bit in our analysis
Bishop g5
yeah oh yeah maybe something around them
to improve with them it's not not much I
think you cannot blame girlfriend too
much too little deep lady tz5 it looked
at it looked like white has a slight
advantage and I also enjoy did you see
the video feed also with the thing they
have their very nice video also of the
players and I think yeah I think I
looked to bit unsettled there couple of
moves a hand and he also said in the
press conference that it was a bit
worried not not usually work but for
that he was kind of fearing to drift
into something uncomfortable so it it's
an understandable choice it's not like
white was playing for a drawer something
of just like that Young may be evaluated
this as slightly better but didn't see
the exact kind of defense set up that
the dilantin came up with yeah I think
this is the start one of the star moves
of the game mcafee i'ts to avoid long
torture yeah yeah this really yeah
clarified Metis I think based on a
chilly outside we should bear fight
before before so um it's my possible and
dumb so now Luke the lights just
reinforced on f5 against g4 and now it
became clear that the bishop really
wasn't a major advantage okay that's
like I've got some audio problems here
but ahh okay all right sure we call it a
day then okay thanks chess explained all
right we'll upload this to our
respective channels I think we've got
some issues now anyway so there's a good
time to break off okay so comments
questions on both of our channels chess
explain and King squash your channels on
YouTube yup things oh yeah okay you got
your back okay Frank thanks so much
Chris okay she's a run